-It's so great to you.
I am the biggest, biggest,
biggest, biggest fan,
but I want to get to know more
about you so everyone knows.
And again, I don't want
to give away any spoilers,
but you were so great on "Ozark"
that I hope you won every award
that was known to man
to give to an actor.
You deserve it.
You were great.
-Wow, thank you.
-That was phenomenal.
-Thank you.
-And I'm reading up about you.
And I go, wait, you got your
start on "Guiding Light"?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-What?
-[ Laughs ]
I started on "Guiding Light"
out of college, you know?
And so, I went
to theater school
and I'm learning
my theater acting...
-Sure.
-My big -- my outdoor acting,
I now call it.
-Yeah.
-And then you go on television.
I had never been in front
of the camera before.
So it was like, what are you
supposed to do?
You know, and people say, like,
you do less or you do nothing.
-Because you're used to
projecting your voice on stage.
-Yeah, your kind of --
your voice and your body.
-Theater.
-And all -- you know, yeah.
-So now you're on camera, yeah.
-So now I'm on camera,
and I'm like,
I'm not going to do anything,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not going to do anything.
-I'm literally
not going to do anything.
And I was like, "Oh, I'm cool.
Like, I bet --
I bet I look cool
and I bet this is, like,
good camera acting."
And because the soap, you know,
like, they --
they air it a month after.
So you're filming
an episode a day,
and they're airing it
a month later.
And that just happens
around the clock.
-It's work.
They go for it on soap operas.
-Yeah.
-It's like, you do like 50 pages
a day or something.
-50 pages a day.
You do an hour a day.
So then a month later, I'm like,
"Now let me see
what my camera acting,
you know, let's see how this
worked out."
-Hello, let's James Dean.
Let's see what happens
if James Dean enters the room.
-Well, James Dean looked like
he had a pole up his butt.
[ Laughter ]
I did.
-It was -- it was terrible?
-It was so bad. It looked
like I was scared to move.
I was like...
-"Hi."
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, really. So, it's awful.
And you saw it, and you go,
"Oh, no, this is rough."
-It was horrible.
-Did your friends and family
say, "Oh, no, dude, Tom, you got
to figure this out."
-No, I -- I was my own
harshest critic.
-You knew it.
-I knew it.
-But it was great, because then
you kind of learn --
learn as you go.
-You just learn to change it.
And then, you ended up winning
two Emmys for it.
-Yeah.
-Dude, yeah.
So you learned how to do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You figured it out.
You know, it's teacher
appreciation week,
and I know that you wanted
to give a shout out
to a certain teacher of yours.
The stage is yours.
The floor is yours.
You can go to camera two
or camera one.
-Yeah, well, when I was
14-years-old in high school,
I had a teacher named
Steve Kasakoff, and, I guess --
I guess he really
changed my life.
You know, he was a man that
introduced me to acting
and gave me my first exposure
to the whole thing.
And he did it with love
and passion,
and he taught me discipline.
And I'm going to get emotional.
He gave me a work ethic.
And I wouldn't be here
or have the life I have
right now without him,
and I'm so grateful for that,
and I'm so grateful
for all the people
and the teachers and the adults
who take time to show
an interest in kids and kind of
turn their lights on.
And -- yeah, happy --
happy teacher week.
-Teacher appreciation.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank you for doing that.
Thank you for saying that.
Love that.
Where would we be
without our teachers?
We're lucky enough
to have teachers.
I mean, he's got to be proud
of your work on "Ozark."
I got to be honest, you play
Ben, you know,
Laura Linney's brother,
you know, on the show.
And I'm watching, you know,
and again, no spoilers,
I'm not quite to the end.
So I don't know anything,
but I do know that what I saw
was just amazing.
And it was just --
it was just --
I was scared of you,
then I loved you.
I rooted for you.
I mean, I didn't love you,
but I rooted for you.
-Right, right.
[ Laughter ]
-And then -- then you got
romantic, so I go,
"Oh, this guy's a romantic."
-Yeah.
-I'm rooting for you guys.
I'm always rooting for love.
And then -- then I didn't know
what was going
to happen with you,
and you made me so nervous,
and I haven't seen
acting like that in a long time.
It was just phenomenal
what you did.
Did you know
when you were doing it?
Like, "Oh, this -- I'm hitting
it out of the park here."
-Oh, no. No.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-Yeah, you don't --
you don't know.
Like, when it -- when it's kind
of really good,
you kind of don't know
really what's happening
and you forget a little bit
and you're not really sure.
But, thankfully I'm surrounded
by, you know,
Laura Linney and Jason Bateman.
And it's like --
-Oh, yeah.
"Are we okay?"
"Yeah, we're good."
-We're good.
-We're just --
-I mean, yeah, they're all --
they're all great actors.
The whole cast is amazing.
-Amazing.
-Everyone scores, obviously.
But I just saw you,
and I was like,
"This guy is just..."
Not even a home run.
Just knocked the cover
off the ball, buddy.
It was amazing.
-Dude, that means so much to me.
-Really, you're great.
And now I want to talk about
"Outer Range."
Okay, this is on Prime Video.
Here, this is -- set this up,
because this is a great --
this is a great plot.
-Yeah. So, I mean,
it's a lot of things.
So, you kind of have this --
it's a modern day
Western family drama, mystery
with a metaphysical element
and crazy neighbors.
[ Laughter ]
-If you can't relate to that,
then I mean that's -- exactly.
[ Laughter ]
No, but it's --
so it's basically -- yeah,
you're on horseback a lot.
You're herding cattle.
There's --
your wife goes missing.
-She's missing, yeah.
When the show starts, she's been
missing for nine months.
And my character, Perry Abbott,
the son of Royal Abbott,
who is played by Josh Brolin,
is sort of --
sort of broken,
sort of -- kind of lost.
His wife's missing,
and he doesn't know why
or what happened.
And they don't know
if she's alive or dead,
and he's sort of in that limbo
when we meet him.
-Yeah.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Tom Pelphrey and
Josh Brolin in "Outer Range."
Take a look at this.
-She said that Rebecca's
not gone.
♪♪
That nothing's ever really gone.
That there's a plan.
♪♪
-What do you mean?
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
And saved you.
-No, this isn't that.
-It brought you here.
-Perry.
♪♪
-Dad.
-Son, listen to me.
-She's right.
-Oh, Tom Pelphrey, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Season one of "Outer Range" is
available now on Prime Video.